veamos tenemos esta gráfica aquí donde t
es la variable independiente en el eje
horizontal y d es la variable
dependiente en el eje vertical y aquí
tenemos esta tabla aparentemente la
tabla corresponde a la gráfica cuando t
es igual a 1 d es igual a 40 cuando t
igualados d es igual 80 así es que estos
valores corresponden a puntos sobre la
recta y luego nos explican estás
comprando una membresía en un gimnasio
la membresía cuesta 40 dólares por mes
en la gráfica y tabla arriba de es el
número total de dólares que pagas por tu
membresía aquí tenemos de ite es el
tiempo en meses que conservas la
membresía escribe una ecuación para la
cantidad de dinero de que pagas por tu
membresía de gimnasio si conservan la
membresía por t meses y aquí lo vemos el
primer mes pagas 40 dólares el segundo
mes pagas otros 40 dólares has pagado 80
dólares
puedes ver eso en la gráfica que tenemos
aquí has estado 0 meses no pagas nada
hace estar un mes pagas 40 dólares el
siguiente mes otros 40 dólares para
llegar a 80 escribamos la ecuación aquí
la variable dependiente aquí
es la cantidad de dólares que pagas y
eso va a depender del tiempo y cómo va a
depender eso del tiempo en meses
bueno vas a pagar 40 dólares mensuales
por el número de meses esto lo puedo
escribir como 40 asterisco te puesto
también lo podemos poner directamente
como 40 te y creo que está bien pues si
mi tiempo es cero de acuerdo con la
tabla o de acuerdo con la gráfica no
pagó nada si hubiera algún costo
inscripción tendríamos que agregar
entonces ese costo inscripción al cual
le tendríamos que sumar la tarifa
mensual pero en este caso parece que
estamos bien el costo en dólares es
igual a 40 por el tiempo en meses el
tiempo es la variable independiente que
determina el valor de la variable
dependiente el costo en dólares que
tienes que pagar